So, Jim, say who you are and say where you are.
那么，吉姆，请介绍一下你自己，并告诉我们你在哪里。
Well, I'm Jim Biederman, and I'm standing in the Hall of the States in the Louvre museum. It's a hall of Italian masters where many of the Italian masters, the Carvaggios and Raphaels and many of the Italian painters from the Venetian period are hung, including Leonardo da Vinci and the Mona Lisa. I'm standing right across the way from the Mona Lisa, as a matter of fact.
嗯，我是吉姆·比德曼，我现在站在卢浮宫的“各邦大厅”。这是一个收藏意大利大师作品的展厅，悬挂着许多意大利大师的画作，比如卡拉瓦乔和拉斐尔，还有威尼斯画派的许多画家的作品，当然也包括列奥纳多·达·芬奇的《蒙娜丽莎》。事实上，我就站在《蒙娜丽莎》的正对面。
And you're speaking to us on a cell phone from there in Paris.
你现在是从巴黎的那里用手机和我们通话吗？
From the actual museum itself.
是的，就在博物馆里面。
I was in Italy once, in Florence. And I went to the museum where they have Michelangelo's statue of David. He holds a slingshot in one hand. You've see pictures of this. And as I stood there, all around the statue were people talking about what restaurant they were going to go to later, when they were going to meet their friends. You know, you stand there and you just think, how good would this statue have to be to actually get their undivided attention? What has an artist got to do?
我曾经去过意大利的佛罗伦萨。我去了一座博物馆，那里有米开朗基罗的《大卫》雕像。他一只手拿着弹弓。你一定见过这张照片。当我站在那里时，雕像周围的人都在讨论一会儿要去哪家餐馆吃饭，什么时候去见朋友。你知道，你站在那儿就会想，这座雕像得有多优秀才能真正吸引他们的全部注意力？艺术家到底该怎么做呢？
And this is not just Michelangelo's problem. We sent out an actual foreign correspondent, Jim Biederman, to the Louvre, and he discovered that Leonardo da Vinci is also having trouble touching people's hearts in the museum setting.
这不仅仅是米开朗基罗的问题。我们派驻卢浮宫的特约记者吉姆·比德曼发现，列奥纳多·达·芬奇在博物馆的环境下，也难以打动人们的心。
Well, one of the great debates that's taking place here around the Mona Lisa is exactly how expensive it is and why it's valued at so much. The people are talking about what it is exactly that makes this painting so special. And I heard one woman say, well, I hear it's her smile. Another woman said, no, no, no. It's her eyes. And she says, her eyes follow you anywhere in the room. And then she says to her friend, go over there in the corner and see if she's looking at you. And she stomps across the room. Is she looking at you over there? Can you see her looking at you over there?
嗯，现在关于《蒙娜丽莎》最大的争论之一，正是它到底有多昂贵，以及为什么它的价值如此之高。人们都在谈论究竟是什么让这幅画如此特别。我听到一位女士说：“嗯，我听说是因为她的微笑。”另一位女士说：“不，不，不。是她的眼睛。”她说，她的眼睛在房间里无论你走到哪里都会跟着你。然后她对她的朋友说：“你去那个角落看看她是不是在看你。”于是她跺着脚穿过房间。“她在那边看你吗？你能看到她在那边盯着你吗？”
So, Jim, do people stand next to the Mona Lisa and talk about things that have nothing to do with the painting at all?
那么，吉姆，人们站在《蒙娜丽莎》旁边时，会聊些与画作完全无关的事情吗？
Oh, absolutely. Yeah. And also you get a lot of people sort of pressed to get other places. "I'm tired, Dad. You said you were going to take us somewhere else." And "Oh, we've seen this. Let's go." And yeah, there's a lot of that.
噢，绝对会。是的。而且你还会看到很多人急着要去别的地方。“我累了，爸爸。你说过要带我们去别的地方的。”还有“哦，我们看过了，走吧。”是的，这种情况非常多。
It actually makes you feel bad for artists, you know? A group most of us feel no sympathy for whatsoever. I mean, imagine an artist's life. It takes years to develop any skills. It's intensely difficult to learn. It's very, very competitive. Almost nobody makes any money doing it. There are jealousies and unfair treatment. And then, if somehow, somehow, your work is recognized and you end up in a museum, perhaps, incredibly, you end up in a world-class museum like the Louvre, this is how you're treated, even here.
这真的让你为艺术家感到难过，你知道吗？这是我们大多数人根本不会产生同情心的一个群体。我的意思是，想象一下艺术家的生活。培养任何技能都需要花费数年时间。学习起来极其困难。竞争非常、非常激烈。几乎没人能靠这个赚到钱。这里充满了嫉妒和不公平的待遇。然后，如果你的作品以某种方式得到了认可，并最终进入了博物馆，也许令人难以置信的是，你最终进入了像卢浮宫这样的世界级博物馆，即便在这里，你受到的待遇也是这样。
One woman stood in front. And she said, I saw in a film once that if you go really close to the painting, she doesn't look that good at all.
一位女士站在前面，她说：“我曾在一部电影里看到，如果你离画作非常近，她看起来根本没那么好看。”
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
What do people want out of art? What are they looking for anyway? Imagine da Vinci's horror if he heard the banality of the following exchange between Jim and I?
人们从艺术中想要得到什么？他们到底在寻找什么？如果达·芬奇听到吉姆和我之间的对话如此平庸，他该有多惊恐？
Jim, is it possible for you to walk over to the Mona Lisa right now?
吉姆，你现在能走到《蒙娜丽莎》旁边吗？
I'm right next to it right now.
我就在它旁边。
You are?
真的吗？
I'm standing right at the rail. There's bulletproof glass in front and a rail that stands out about five feet here that keeps people away. It's quite a lovely painting. And it's true. Her eyes do follow you everywhere.
我就站在护栏边。前面有防弹玻璃，还有一个突出约五英尺的护栏，把人们隔开。这真是一幅很美的画。而且这是真的，她的眼睛确实在到处跟着你。
They do?
真的吗？
Yes, I'm off to the side right now, but if I go across-- and I'll just do this for you, Ira, because I know that this is real radio here. So I'm going to go over to the other side here. And I'm in the center now, and she's looking straight at me. She's got that enigmatic smile. She looks like she might be smirking a bit at these tourists. I could be wrong. And now I'm over on the left side, and she's still staring at me over here.
是的，我现在站在侧面，但如果我走到对面——艾拉，我这就为你演示一下，因为我知道这是真实的广播。我要走到另一边去。我现在站在中间，她正盯着我看。她有着那种神秘的微笑。她看起来好像在暗自嘲笑这些游客。我可能错了。现在我走到左边，她依然在这儿盯着我。
Well, today on our program, people who thought that they actually knew better about art, better than me, better than Jim. And they actually became artists. And what happened to them. From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Our program today, Blame It on Art. Act One, the cutthroat world of balloon animal artists. No kidding, balloon animal artists.
嗯，今天在我们的节目中，我们邀请了那些认为自己比我、比吉姆更懂艺术的人。他们后来真的成为了艺术家，看看他们经历了什么。来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，这里是《这就是美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目主题是“怪罪艺术”。第一幕，气球动物艺术家们的残酷世界。不开玩笑，真的是气球动物艺术家。
Act Two, writer David Sedaris recounts his own shameful career as a performance artist and how his toenail clippings ended up in a museum.
第二幕，作家大卫·塞达里斯讲述了他自己作为行为艺术家的尴尬职业生涯，以及他的脚趾甲剪是如何进入博物馆的。
Act Three, Reverb, how a hard core jazz snob learned to love what some would consider the worst music in the world, the music his father played.
第三幕，回响，一个铁杆爵士乐势利眼如何学会喜爱某些人认为世界上最烂的音乐——他父亲演奏的音乐。
Act Four, Grace Note, a story from New York locksmith Joel Kostman. Stay with us.
第四幕，装饰音，来自纽约锁匠乔尔·科斯特曼的故事。请继续收听。
Act One, Life in a Bubble. In the world of the artist, successes and failures are all carefully measured, people hold grudges, people are accused of selling out. You find these stories everywhere, the independent rock scene in Chicago or Seattle, the galleries in SoHo, the theater scene pretty much anywhere that theater is made anywhere on this planet. But you might not expect to find these kinds of stories at the Toy Fair. The Toy Fair is the big trade show for the toy world. Thousands of manufacturers and buyers descend on New York City for the event every year. Our contributing editor Paul Tough went with Aaron Hsu-Flanders, a toy entrepreneur.
第一幕，气泡中的生活。在艺术家的世界里，成功和失败都被仔细衡量，人们记仇，人们被指责出卖理想。你在任何地方都能发现这些故事，无论是芝加哥或西雅图的独立摇滚圈、苏豪区的画廊，还是这个星球上任何制作戏剧的地方。但你可能没想到会在玩具展上发现这些故事。玩具展是玩具界的大型贸易展览。每年都有成千上万的制造商和买家涌向纽约参加这一盛会。我们的特约编辑保罗·塔夫与玩具创业者亚伦·徐-弗兰德斯一同前往。
Aaron and I are walking through the entrance hall of the Jacob Javits Center, just hanging out, talking when suddenly we see Amazing [? Shoney. ?] He's got the whole outfit on, painted face, polka-dotted shirt, baggy pants, really, really big shoes. He's a clown all right. And he's doing what clowns do. He's making balloon animals.
亚伦和我正走在贾各布·贾维茨中心的大厅里，随意闲聊，突然我们看到了“神奇的肖尼”。他穿着全套行头，画着脸，穿着波点衬衫、宽松的裤子，鞋子大得离谱。他显然是个小丑。他正在做小丑该做的事：制作气球动物。
You have a magical day now.
祝你有神奇的一天。
Shoney hands Aaron a lopsided pink inflated giraffe. He's just made a balloon animal for one of the acknowledged masters of the art, Aaron Hsu-Flanders, author of Balloon Animals , More Balloon Animals , Balloon Hats and Accessories , and Balloon Cartoons and Other Favorites. It's a weird moment. It's as if Michael Jordan stopped by a schoolyard and played a little one-on-one with an unsuspecting teenager. Aaron doesn't let on who he is. And the two of them just chat for a few minutes about some of the current issues in balloon sculpting.
肖尼递给亚伦一只歪歪扭扭的粉色充气长颈鹿。他刚刚为气球艺术的公认大师之一制作了一只气球动物，这位大师就是亚伦·徐-弗兰德斯，他是《气球动物》、《更多气球动物》、《气球帽子和配饰》以及《气球卡通和其他最爱》的作者。这是一个奇特的时刻。就好像迈克尔·乔丹走进学校操场，和一个毫无防备的青少年玩了一场一对一。亚伦没有透露自己的身份。他们两人随口聊了几分钟关于气球造型目前的一些话题。
I haven't been able to make a good Barney. Can you make Barney? I make him a tyrannosaurus rex that's purple. It doesn't quite look like it. But it's enough to pass.
我一直没能做出好的巴尼（小恐龙）。你会做巴尼吗？我做的是紫色的霸王龙。虽然不太像，但也凑合。
We take our giraffe and walk away. Aaron tells me what he thinks.
我们拿着长颈鹿走开了。亚伦告诉我他的想法。
I wasn't blown away. He made a sort of generic-looking combination dog giraffe kind of thing that you couldn't-- it was more the power of suggestion. He was sort of a follower of the theory that all balloon animals are essentially dogs with a little variation here and there. Lacked a little of the finesse that I admit I have to sort of insist upon in order to be impressed with someone.
我没觉得惊艳。他做的是一种类似狗和长颈鹿的混合体，你没法……更多是靠联想。他倾向于认为所有气球动物本质上都是狗，只是稍微变了下花样。缺乏一点技巧，我承认，为了对某人印象深刻，我必须坚持这种技巧。
Aaron's been making animals out of balloons for more than 20 years. And if anyone in the world of balloon animals is an artist, Aaron is. He invented quite a few designs. It was Aaron, for instance, who made the first balloon camel ever. Amazing [? Shoney ?] may not have recognized him. But here at Toy Fair, especially where balloon people gather, he's constantly being noticed.
亚伦制作气球动物已经超过20年了。如果说气球动物界有艺术家的话，那一定是亚伦。他发明了相当多的设计。例如，正是亚伦制作了有史以来的第一只气球骆驼。“神奇的肖尼”可能没认出他，但在这里的玩具展上，尤其是气球从业者聚集的地方，他总是被人认出来。
Aaron, I've seen you on television.
亚伦，我在电视上见过你。
Have you?
是吗？
Yeah.
是的。
What show?
什么节目？
QVC.
QVC购物频道。
Just recently.
就在最近。
Yeah. $13.18.
是的，13.18美元。
The memory. You got it.
记忆力不错。你记住了。
It's not a total surprise that this guy recognized Aaron. He's in the balloon animal business too. The product that Aaron, sells that he's here at Toy Fair to market, is an instruction book on how to make balloon animals packaged together with 40 balloons and an inflating pump. And the package that this guy sells is suspiciously similar. We walk away from the booth, and Aaron tells me he's used to this sort of thing. There have been eight knockoffs of his product before this one.
这个人认出亚伦并不意外。他也做气球动物生意。亚伦在这里推销的产品是一本气球动物制作教程，随书附赠40个气球和一个充气筒。而这个人卖的产品和亚伦的非常相似。我们离开展位后，亚伦告诉我他习惯了这种事。在这之前已经有八种仿冒他产品的商品了。
Clearly he came out with quite a few direct yes knockoff products. His whole line virtually is a knockoff product. I think he felt like he had to pal up to me a little bit. I am, in a somewhat obscure field, perhaps the acknowledged master at this point.
显然他推出了一些直接的——没错，是仿冒产品。他的整条产品线几乎都是仿冒的。我想他觉得必须跟我套近乎。在某种程度上，我目前是这个相对冷门领域公认的大师。
He's got no boss, no set hours. He makes little kids happy. It seems like a dream job, but it's not his dream. His dream is to be an artist, a real artist. What he really wants to be doing is this.
他没有老板，没有固定的工作时间。他给小孩子们带来快乐。这看起来像是一份梦想的工作，但这并不是他的梦想。他的梦想是成为一名艺术家，真正的艺术家。他真正想做的是这个。
[GUITAR MUSIC PLAYING]
[吉他音乐播放]
I mean, for a long time I did have a love-hate relationship with balloons. And it took me a while to get over that. There is a sort of darker side. This isn't something that I always thought I would do my whole life. It's not the mark that I had ever intended for my whole life to make on the world. And I am a musician, and I actually have always hoped and continue to hope to make a musical mark in some way on the world also. I consider balloons more a craft and music more an art. And I've always considered myself first and foremost a musician.
我的意思是，有很长一段时间，我对气球确实有一种爱恨交织的感觉。我花了一些时间才克服它。这里确实有更阴暗的一面。这并不是我一直认为我会做一辈子的事。这也不是我曾打算在世界上留下的痕迹。我是一名音乐家，实际上，我一直希望并且依然希望以某种方式在世界上留下音乐印记。我把气球更多地视为一种手艺，而把音乐视为艺术。我一直把自己首先视为一名音乐家。
[GUITAR MUSIC PLAYING]
[吉他音乐播放]
This is from a CD called The Blue Jester that Aaron and his friend David recorded a few years ago. Aaron produced it himself, and he distributes it out of his home. When Aaron was in his twenties his life revolved around music. And balloons were just something he did for money, making animals at parties to help pay the rent. Most of his friends were in the same boat, concentrating on their art or their music and working odd jobs for money. It was one of those tightly knit artistic communities where everyone's more or less at the same level of success, everyone has the same values, everyone's supporting one another. And then things changed. In 1989, when he was 29, Aaron published his first book, an 80-page paperback with black and white photos that explained how to make 20 of the most common balloon animals-- giraffes, poodles, dachshunds, elephants. It did pretty well.
这是出自一张名为《蓝色小丑》的CD，是亚伦和他的朋友大卫几年前录制的。亚伦亲自制作并在家中发行。亚伦二十多岁时，他的生活围绕着音乐。气球只是他赚钱的手段，在派对上做动物来支付房租。他大多数朋友也处境相同，专注于艺术或音乐，同时做零工维持生计。那是一个紧密相连的艺术社区，大家成功程度大致相当，有着相同的价值观，互相支持。后来情况变了。1989年，29岁那年，亚伦出版了他的第一本书，一本80页的平装书，配有黑白照片，解释了如何制作20种最常见的气球动物——长颈鹿、贵宾犬、腊肠犬、大象。销量相当不错。
When the moniker best-seller was added to my book, suddenly I had some serious issues of jealousy and envy from almost all of my particularly male friends at that point in my life. I noticed that questions of success and failure and contentment with their own lives were brought to the fore, that this sort of forced the question. Like, oh, Aaron had a best-seller. So that still is an issue.
当“畅销书”这个标签加到我的书上时，我突然从我当时大部分尤其是男性朋友那里感受到了严重的嫉妒和羡慕。我注意到，关于成功、失败以及对自身生活满意度的问题被摆到了台面上，这在某种程度上强迫人们面对这些问题。就像，“哦，亚伦有了畅销书。”所以这至今仍是个问题。
Did balloons actually sort of come between you and certain friends permanently?
气球真的让你和某些朋友的关系彻底破裂了吗？
Yeah, that's actually sad. I had to end very long-term, meaningful friendships for me.
是的，这真的很伤感。我不得不结束了一些对我来说非常长期且有意义的友谊。
As the business got more successful, Aaron's friends, especially his male friends, became more and more critical. He bought a house. He bought a car. He got married. He had kids. All paid for by balloon animals. In his eyes, he was still part of that same creative community. In their eyes, he'd gone corporate.
随着生意越来越成功，亚伦的朋友，特别是男性朋友，变得越来越挑剔。他买了房子，买了车，结婚了，有了孩子。这一切都是靠气球动物赚来的。在他眼里，他依然是那个创意社区的一员。在他们眼里，他已经“企业化”了。
I bemoan the loss of my male friends. That's the irony that my wife and I share all the time is that I'm a person who-- very friendly, amiable person who has thousands of acquaintances, but I have virtually no friends, really close friends.
我哀叹失去了我的男性朋友。我妻子和我经常会分享这样一个讽刺点：我是一个非常友好、和蔼的人，拥有成千上万的熟人，但我几乎没有朋友，没有真正亲密的朋友。
It's an old story, a group of struggling artists. One of them makes it big. The rest feel threatened and bitter. The thing that's incredible, though, about Aaron's story, is that true, he's on top, but he's on top of the world of balloon animals. He takes out a couple of long, thin balloons, the tools of his trade, and starts to demonstrate his craft.
这是一个老套的故事，一群挣扎的艺术家，其中一个成功了，其他人感到被威胁和怨恨。然而，关于亚伦的故事令人不可思议的是，虽然他确实处于顶峰，但他处的是气球动物界的顶峰。他拿出两个细长的气球，他的看家工具，开始演示他的手艺。
[BALLOONS SQUEAKING]
[气球摩擦声]
That's it.
就是这样。
Very nice.
非常棒。
A few squeaks later. Hard to convey, I think, over the radio, but what was just created during that little squeaky period was a teddy bear.
几声吱吱声过后。我觉得在广播里很难传达，但刚才那阵吱吱声中产生的东西是一只泰迪熊。
It says something about human nature that even in this world of teddy bears and giraffes, success is so threatening that becoming king of the balloon animals can destroy a community, turn lifelong friends against one another.
这说明了人性中的某些东西，即使在这个泰迪熊和长颈鹿的世界里，成功也是如此具有威胁性，以至于成为气球动物之王可能会摧毁一个社区，让多年好友反目成仇。
One of my closest friends just recently, after all these years, although there had been a significant period of estrangement, I had to-- we virtually are not in touch at all anymore.
最近，我的一位密友在多年以后，尽管经历了一段漫长的疏远期，我不得不……我们几乎已经不再联系了。
Aaron tells me about this one friend of his, a friend since childhood, who composes contemporary classical music. Not too many people in that world make it big. And his friend apparently wasn't one of the lucky few. He ended up in a job he hated, teaching music at a small New England college. Not enough time to compose. Not enough respect from the New York musical world. As their fortunes went in opposite directions, things between Aaron and his friend became tense.
亚伦跟我谈到了他的一位朋友，儿时的玩伴，专门作曲当代古典音乐。在这个领域没几个人能成功。而他的朋友显然不是那几个幸运儿之一。他最终做着自己讨厌的工作，在一家新英格兰的小学院教音乐。没有足够的时间作曲。在纽约音乐界也得不到足够的尊重。随着他们的境遇背道而驰，亚伦和他的朋友之间的关系变得紧张起来。
But it just turned into-- it was amazing, actually. He very much personalized his bitterness and attacks on what he perceived as the commercial world. But he focused it through the tiny lens of me and the world of commerce but included attacks on the frivolousness of the toy world with lines like, glad to see such creative minds are being dedicated to the world of commerce. It's not like I started manufacturing guns or weaponry or pesticides. He very much gave me the impression that he felt that I was no different than any other businessman who sells [BLEEP] to whatever.
但结果变成……真的很惊人。他非常个人化地表达了他的怨恨，抨击他所认为的商业世界。但他通过我这个狭小的视角集中攻击，并包含了对玩具世界轻浮的抨击，说着类似“很高兴看到如此创意的头脑被奉献给商业世界”这样的话。好像我开始制造枪支、武器或杀虫剂似的。他非常明确地让我感到，他认为我和任何其他向无论谁兜售垃圾的商人没有什么不同。
Aaron says that he's tired of defending himself from that sort of attack. But the fact is, those are the very questions he asks himself when he's alone. Is he an artist, or is he a salesman?
亚伦说他厌倦了为这类攻击辩护。但事实是，这些正是他独自一人时会问自己的问题。他是艺术家，还是推销员？
These days he finds himself hanging out less and less with creative people and more and more with store owners and distributors and latex manufacturers. There are some people he meets in the toy world that he likes, people he feels a real connection with, but he says it doesn't happen all that often.
这些天，他发现自己与有创意的人来往越来越少，而与店主、经销商和乳胶制造商往来越来越多。他在玩具世界里遇到了一些喜欢的人，他感到与之有真正的联系，但他说这种情况并不常发生。
There is a certain part of me that gets really alienated when I walk around here. I hate to say this, but I look around, and it just doesn't seem like there's anyone that I really care too much about.
当我在这里走动时，我内心确实有一部分会感到非常疏离。我不想这么说，但我环顾四周，似乎真的没有什么人是我特别在乎的。
What's happened to Aaron is what happens to a lot of creative people who find some measure of success. Without meaning to, he has become a businessman. He's really good at it. But he says sometimes he loses track of how he ended up here.
亚伦身上发生的事，是许多获得一定成功的创意人士身上都会发生的事情。他无意中成为了一名商人。而且他干得很出色。但他说，有时候他会忘记自己是如何走到这一步的。
[MUSIC - "TEARS OF A CLOWN" BY THE ENGLISH BEAT]
[音乐 - 《小丑的眼泪》，英国Beat乐队]
Act Two, Still Life. After high school, writer David Sedaris attended an unusual number of colleges for very brief periods of time, hoping somehow that one of them would turn him into an artist, even though he had no skill at all at painting, drawing, sculpting, printmaking, or any of the known visual media. For instance, he enrolled in the art program at a school that was mainly known for its animal husbandry program, where he fell in with an arty crowd of filmmakers, lazy filmmakers.
第二幕，静物。高中毕业后，作家大卫·塞达里斯在极短的时间内上了多所不同寻常的大学，希望能通过某种方式成为艺术家，尽管他在绘画、素描、雕塑、版画或任何已知的视觉媒体方面根本没有天赋。例如，他报名参加了一所主要以畜牧专业闻名的学校的艺术课程，在那里他结识了一群热爱艺术的电影制作人，一群懒散的电影制作人。
In their company, I attended grainy black and white movies in which ponderous, turtlenecked men walked the stony beaches, cursing the gulls for their ability to fly. Art was based upon despair, and the important thing was to make yourself and those around you as miserable as possible. Maybe I couldn't paint or sculpt, but I could work a mood better than anyone I knew. Unfortunately, the school had no accredited sulking program. And I dropped out more despondent than ever.
在他们的陪伴下，我看了黑白颗粒感的电影，片中那些沉闷的、穿高领毛衣的男人走在多石的海滩上，诅咒着海鸥的飞行能力。艺术建立在绝望之上，重要的是让你自己和周围的人尽可能地痛苦。也许我不会画画或雕塑，但我营造情绪的能力比我认识的任何人都强。不幸的是，学校没有经过认证的“闷闷不乐”课程。我辍学了，比以往任何时候都更加沮丧。
This was recorded in front of a live audience in Seattle by public radio station KUOW. A warning to listeners before we begin, in this story David Sedaris mentions the fact that sex exists, and he talks about drug use with a level of detail and familiarity you do not usually hear from other public radio commentators like, say, Daniel Schorr.
这段录音是由公共广播电台KUOW在西雅图的现场观众面前录制的。在开始之前给听众一个警告：在这个故事中，大卫·塞达里斯提到了性存在的事实，并以一种你通常不会从其他公共广播评论员（比如丹尼尔·肖尔）那里听到的细节和熟悉程度谈论了毒品使用。
After a few months in my parents' basement, I took an apartment near the state university where I discovered both crystal methamphetamine and conceptual art. Either one of these things is dangerous enough, but the combination has the potential to destroy entire civilizations.
在父母的地下室住了几个月后，我在州立大学附近租了一间公寓，在那里我发现了结晶甲基苯丙胺和观念艺术。这两者中的任何一个都足够危险，但结合在一起就有可能摧毁整个文明。
The moment I took my first burning snootful, I understood that this was the drug for me. Speed eliminates all doubt. Am I smart enough? Will people like me? Do I really look all right in this plastic jumpsuit? These are questions for insecure potheads. A speed enthusiast knows that everything he says or does is brilliant, the upswing being that, having eliminated the need for both eating and sleeping, you have a full 24 hours a day to spread your charm and talent.
我吸进第一口灼热气息的那一刻，我就明白这是适合我的毒品。冰毒消除了所有疑虑。“我够聪明吗？人们会喜欢我吗？我穿这件塑料连体衣真的好看吗？”这些是那些缺乏安全感的瘾君子的问题。冰毒爱好者知道他说的或做的每一件事都是天才之举，好处在于，消除了饮食和睡眠的需求，你有整整24小时的时间来传播你的魅力和才华。
"For god's sake," my father would say, "it's 4 o'clock in the morning. What are you calling for?" I was calling because the rest of my friends had taken to unplugging their phones after 10:00 PM. These were people I had known in high school, and it disappointed me to see how little we now had in common. These people were all stuck in the past, setting up their booths at the art fair and thinking themselves successful because they'd sold a silk screen picturing a footprint in the sand. Didn't they read any of the magazines? The new breed of artists wanted nothing to do with beauty. Here were people who made a living pitching tents or lying in a fetal position before our national monuments.
“看在上帝的份上，”我父亲会说，“现在是凌晨4点。你打电话干什么？”我打电话是因为我的其他朋友都在晚上10点后拔掉了电话线。这些人是我高中时认识的，看到我们现在如此疏远，我感到很失望。这些人全都困在过去，在艺术博览会上支起摊位，认为自己很成功，因为他们卖出了一幅画着沙滩脚印的丝网印刷画。他们没读过任何杂志吗？新一代的艺术家不想和“美”有任何关系。这里的人靠搭帐篷或在国家纪念碑前蜷缩成胎儿姿势为生。
One fellow had made a name for himself by allowing a friend to shoot him in the shoulder. This was the art world I'd been dreaming of, where god-given talent was considered a hindrance. "Let me put your mother on," my father would say. "She's had a few drinks, and maybe she can understand whatever the hell it is you're talking about."
有个家伙允许朋友射中他的肩膀，以此成名。这就是我梦想中的艺术世界，天赋被视为障碍。“让我把你妈叫来，”我父亲会说，“她喝了几杯酒，也许她能听懂你到底在说些什么鬼话。”
I bought my drugs from a wiry, pop-eyed short-order cook whose brittle, prematurely white hair was teased in such a way that I couldn't look at her without thinking of a dandelion. The drug had a way of turning people into either really good sex partners or very bad artists. And she seemed to know exactly which group I might fit into. She introduced me to a handful of jittery motormouths who shared my love of the word manifesto. The first meeting was tense, but I broke the ice by laying out a few lines of crystal and commenting on my host's refreshing lack of furniture. This was an understatement, as his living room contained nothing but an enormous nest made from human hair. It seemed the man drove twice a week to all the local salons and barber shops, collecting their sweepings and arranging them strand by strand, as carefully as a wren. "I've been building this nest for, oh, about six months now," he said. "Go ahead. Have a seat."
我从一个双眼突出、瘦骨嶙峋的快餐厨师那里买毒品，她那脆弱、过早花白的头发梳成一种形状，让我想起了一朵蒲公英。这种毒品有一种魔力，能把人变成非常好的性伴侣或者非常糟糕的艺术家。她似乎确切地知道我属于哪一类。她把我介绍给几个语速飞快、神经质的人，他们和我一样热爱“宣言”这个词。第一次见面很紧张，但我通过摆出几行冰毒并评论主人缺乏家具这一点来打破了僵局。这说轻了，因为他的客厅除了一个用人头发做成的巨大巢穴外什么都没有。看来这个男人每周两次驱车前往当地所有的沙龙和理发店，收集废料，像鹪鹩一样仔细地一根一根排列。“我已经建这个巢大约六个月了，”他说，“来吧，坐下。”
Inspired by my friends, I started on a few pieces of my own. My first project was a series of wooden vegetable crates I filled with my garbage. Seeing as I no longer ate anything, there were no rotting food scraps to worry about, just cigarette butts, aspirin tins, wads of hair, and bloody Kleenex. Because this was art, I meticulously recorded each entry using an ink I'd made from the crushed bodies of ticks and mosquitoes. 2:17 AM. Four toe nail clippings, dust from window sill, moth. I was a busy man. When two of my crates were completed, I carried them down to the art museum for consideration in the upcoming juried biennial. The next few weeks were spent basically camping out beside my mailbox waiting to hear what the state of North Carolina had to say about the artistic merits of my toenail clippings. When the news arrived that I had been accepted, I should have kept the information to myself. My friends' proposals to set fire to the grand staircase and sculpt the governor's head out of human feces had all been rejected. This confirmed their outsider status and made me suspect.
在朋友的启发下，我开始创作自己的作品。我的第一个项目是一系列木制蔬菜板条箱，里面装满了我的垃圾。因为我什么都不吃，所以不用担心腐烂的食物残渣，只有烟蒂、阿司匹林罐、头发团和带血的纸巾。因为这是艺术，我用一种我用被压碎的蜱虫和蚊子尸体制成的墨水，一丝不苟地记录了每一个条目。凌晨2:17。四片脚趾甲，窗台上的灰尘，飞蛾。我是一个大忙人。当我的两个板条箱完成后，我把它们带到艺术博物馆，供即将到来的评审双年展审议。接下来的几周，我基本上住在邮箱旁边，等着听北卡罗来纳州对我的脚趾甲剪的艺术价值有何评价。当得知被入选的消息时，我本应该保密的。我朋友们关于纵火烧毁大楼梯、用人类粪便雕刻州长头像的提案都被拒绝了。这证实了他们“局外人”的地位，也让我受到了怀疑。
At the next group meeting, it was suggested that the museum had accepted my work only because it was decorative and easy to swallow. My friends could have gotten in if they'd compromised themselves, but unlike me, that was not their style. After the exhibit had ended, I burned my crates, storing the ashes in a Tupperware bowl I kept in the back of my closet. I told my friends that I hated every moment of the museum reception. Only then did I find myself back in the group's good graces. I had paid for my folly and as a reward was invited to take part in the nest builder's performance piece. He held a meeting where seven of us chirped and bleated what amounted to the script. I wanted to point out that I'd had a bit of acting experience in the past, but covered to the waste in human hair, it seemed best not to mention it.
在下一次小组会议上，有人暗示博物馆接受我的作品仅仅是因为它具有装饰性且易于接受。如果我的朋友们愿意妥协，他们也能入选，但与我不同，那不是他们的风格。展览结束后，我烧毁了我的板条箱，把灰烬存放在一个放在壁橱后面的特百惠碗里。我告诉我的朋友我讨厌博物馆招待会的每一刻。只有这样，我才重新赢得了团队的好感。我为自己的愚蠢付出了代价，作为奖励，我被邀请参加“筑巢者”的行为艺术表演。他开了一个会，我们七个人在那儿唧唧喳喳地念着表演脚本。我想指出我过去有一点表演经验，但全身覆盖着人发，最好还是别提了。
One of the cast members stormed out in tears after being told she wasn't moaning properly, and the rest of us suffered a continuing plague of splinters and heat rashes. I never understood what the piece was about and never asked because I didn't want to appear stupid. My parents attended the premiere, sitting cross-legged on one of the mats spread like islands across the filthy concrete floor. The local newspaper ran a review headlined, "Local Group Pitches in, Cleans up Warehouse." This did nothing to encourage ticket buyers whose numbers dwindled to the single digits by the second night of our weeklong run. Luckily we found it easy to blame not ourselves but a public so brainwashed by television that they found it impossible to sit through a two and a half hour performance piece without complaining of boredom and leg cramps.
其中一名演员在被告知她呻吟得不恰当时哭着冲了出去，我们其他人则遭受着源源不断的木刺和热疹的折磨。我从不明白这件作品是关于什么的，也从不问，因为我不想显得愚蠢。我的父母参加了首演，盘腿坐在铺在肮脏混凝土楼板上的垫子上，像岛屿一样散布着。当地报纸发表了一篇评论，标题是“当地团体齐心协力，清理仓库”。这并没有鼓励到购票者，到我们为期一周表演的第二天，人数就降到了个位数。幸运的是，我们很容易责怪的不是自己，而是一个被电视洗脑的公众，他们发现坐两个半小时的行为艺术表演而不抱怨无聊和腿抽筋是不可能的。
When the nest builder announced his plans for the next piece, the group fell apart. "Why is it always your piece?" We asked. When he offered us the opportunity to create our own parts, we became even angrier. Who was he to give assignments and set deadlines? The truth was that we lacked the ability to invent our own roles. This led to a climactic shouting match wherein we exhausted all our analogies, and started all over again from the top. "We're not your puppets or your little trained dogs willing to jump through some hoop. What, do you think we're puppets? Is that what you think? Do I look like a puppet to you? I'm not a puppet or a little dog either. I'm not going to jump through any of your hoops, puppet master, because I'm not a dog or a puppet. You can train a dog to jump through a hoop. Buy yourself a dog, why don't you? Better yet, get a puppet, because you've pulled these strings for the last time." I had hoped the group might stick together for years, but within 10 minutes, it was all over, finished, each of us pledging to perform on our own.
当筑巢者宣布他下一个作品的计划时，团队解散了。“为什么总是你的作品？”我们问。当他给我们机会创作自己的部分时，我们变得更加愤怒。他算什么，能布置任务和设定截止日期？事实是我们缺乏发明自己角色的能力。这导致了一场激烈的争吵，我们用尽了所有的类比，然后又从头开始。“我们不是你的傀儡，也不是愿意钻圈的小狗。你觉得我们是傀儡吗？这就是你认为的吗？我看起来像傀儡吗？我不是傀儡也不是小狗。我不会钻你的圈套，操纵者，因为我不是狗也不是傀儡。你可以训练狗钻圈套。干嘛不去买只狗？最好买个傀儡，因为你这是最后一次拉动这些线了。”我曾希望团队能坚持几年，但在10分钟内，一切都结束了，完成历史使命，我们每个人都发誓要单独表演。
I spent the next few weeks running the argument over and over in my mind, picturing a small dog chasing a puppet across the floor of an abandoned warehouse. I was stuffing a pillow with my cigarette butts when the museum called inviting me to participate in their month of Sundays performance festival. Watching the performances of my former colleagues, I got the idea that once you'd assembled the requisite props, the piece would come together on its own. The inflatable shark led naturally to the puddle of heavy cream, which, if lapped from the floor with a slow, steady precision, could amount to up to 20 minutes of valuable stage time. This revelation led me to a secondhand store where I searched the aisles with the cold eye of a prospector. Standing at the checkout counter with an armload of sock monkeys, I told the cashier, "These are for a piece I'm working on. It's a performance commissioned by the art museum. I'm an artist." "So is my niece." The woman stabbed her cigarette into a bucket full of sand. "She's the one who made those monkeys."
接下来的几周里，我一直在脑海中反复重演那场争论，脑补着一只小狗在废弃仓库的地板上追逐傀儡的画面。我正用烟蒂往枕头里填充时，博物馆打来电话，邀请我参加他们的“周日之月”表演节。观看前同事的表演时，我萌生了一个想法：一旦你集齐了必要的道具，作品自然会拼凑在一起。充气鲨鱼自然引导出了一滩浓奶油，如果用缓慢、稳定的精确度从地板上舔食，可以争取多达20分钟的宝贵舞台时间。这一启发引导我来到一家二手店，我用探矿者般冷酷的眼光搜寻着过道。站在收银台前，怀里抱着一堆袜子猴，我告诉收银员：“这些是我正在创作的作品的道具。这是艺术博物馆委托的行为艺术。我是艺术家。”“我侄女也是。”那个女人把香烟戳进装满沙子的桶里。“那些猴子就是她做的。”
It disturbed me to hear the word artist used so loosely. The man who sketched portraits at the mall called himself an artist, as did the woman who forged wreaths out of used Styrofoam cups. "Yes," I said, "but I'm a real artist." The woman was not offended, only puzzled. "But my niece lives over near Winston-Salem." She said it as though she were referring to a well-known art capital where the streets were lined with galleries and pastry shops. "She's a big blond-headed girl with twin babies. Maybe you know of her. Her name's Lucille, but everybody calls her Sock Lady on account of she's always making those monkeys. Pretty girl. Fat in the rear, but just as pretty and talented as she can be." I looked into this woman's face. Maybe one day I'd do a piece about stupidity, but right now I'd just pay for these sock monkeys, snort a few lines of speed, and finish constructing a bulletproof vest out of used flashlight batteries.
听到“艺术家”这个词被如此随意地使用，我感到不安。在商场画肖像的人自称是艺术家，用废旧聚苯乙烯杯做花环的女人也这样自称。“是的，”我说，“但我是一名真正的艺术家。”那个女人没有被冒犯，只是很困惑。“但我侄女住在温斯顿-塞勒姆附近。”她说得好像那是一个著名的艺术之都，街上到处都是画廊和糕点店。“她是个大个子金发女孩，有两个双胞胎宝宝。也许你听说过她。她叫露西尔，但大家都叫她‘袜子女士’，因为她总是做那些猴子。漂亮的女孩。后面很胖，但确实很漂亮，非常有才华。”我看着这个女人的脸。也许有一天我会创作一件关于愚蠢的作品，但现在我还是付钱买下这些袜子猴，吸几口冰毒，然后完成用废旧手电筒电池制作防弹背心的工作。
There was a good-sized crowd gathered at the art museum, and I stood before them, wishing they were half as high as I was. I'd been up for three days and nights and had taken so much speed that I could see the individual atoms pitching in to make up every folding chair. For the first few minutes, I thought it was my paranoia until I remembered that these people were staring at me for a reason. I was here to perform. The show wasn't over yet. It hadn't even started.
艺术博物馆聚集了相当多的人，我站在他们面前，希望他们能像我一样兴奋。我已经三天三夜没睡了，吸了太多的冰毒，以至于我能看到构成每把折叠椅的每一个原子。前几分钟，我以为是我的偏执，后来才想起这些人盯着我看是有原因的。我是来表演的。演出还没有结束，甚至还没开始。
I tried reminding myself that I was in control. All I had to do was open my prop bag, and the rest of the piece would take care of itself. I'm slicing the pineapple now, I thought. Next I'll rip apart these sock monkeys and pour the stuffing into this tall rubber boot. Good. That's good. Now I'll snip off some of my hair with these garden shears, stare at my hands for a while, and then we're almost home. I moved towards the audience and was kneeling in the aisle, the shears is to my head when I heard, "I can't get him to touch the damn things at home." It was my father, speaking in a loud voice to the woman seated beside him. "I could never get him to cut his hair either. I guess the barber shop isn't artsy enough for him." The audience begin to laugh. For the first time since I'd started, they perked up and began enjoying themselves.
我试图提醒自己，我掌控着局面。我只需要打开道具包，剩下的表演自然会水到渠成。我正在切菠萝，我想。接下来我要撕开这些袜子猴，把填充物倒进这只高筒橡胶靴里。很好。这就很好。现在我要用这些园艺剪剪掉一些头发，盯着自己的手看一会儿，然后我们就快大功告成了。我走向观众，跪在过道里，正要把剪刀伸向自己的头时，听到：“我在家都无法让他碰那些该死的东西。”是我父亲，正在向身旁坐着的女人大声说话。“我也从没让他剪过头发。我猜理发店对他来说不够艺术。”观众开始笑了。这是我开始表演以来，他们第一次振作起来，开始享受其中。
"Hey, sport, what do you charge for a shave?" It was him again, and once again, the crowd responded. Their laughter egged him on, and he proceeded to deliver a running commentary. Drunk with attention, he ruined my piece with his snide little comments. I was literally spitting tacks, trying my hardest to concentrate.
“嘿，哥们，理个发要多少钱？”又是他，人群再次回应。他们的笑声怂恿着他，他继续喋喋不休地发表着现场评论。因这种关注而醉心，他用那些尖刻的小评论毁了我的表演。我真的气坏了，极力试图集中注意力。
Immediately following the performance, a sizable crowd gathered around my father, congratulating him on his delivery and comic timing. "Including your father was an excellent idea," the curator said, handing me my check. "The piece really picked up once you relaxed and started making fun of yourself."
表演刚结束，一大群人围住了我父亲，恭喜他的表现和喜剧时机。“邀请你父亲是个极好的主意，”策展人一边递给我支票一边说，“当你放松下来开始拿自己开涮时，这件作品真的出彩了。”
Not only did my father ask for a cut of the money, but he also started calling with suggestions for future pieces. "What if you were to symbolize man's inhumanity to man by heating up a skillet of plastic soldiers? I told him it was the lamest idea I'd ever heard in my life and to stop calling me with his pissy little ideas. "I'm an artist," I yelled. "I come up with the ideas. Not you, me. This isn't a party game. It's serious work, and I'd rather chew on blasting caps than listen to any more of your suggestions." There was a brief pause before he said, "The bit with the blasting caps just might work. Let me think about it and get back to you."
我父亲不仅要求分成，还开始打电话为未来的作品提建议。“如果你通过加热一平底锅塑料士兵来象征人对人的残酷，会怎样？”我告诉他这是我听过的最烂的主意，让他别再用他那卑劣的小点子给我打电话了。“我是艺术家，”我大喊。“主意是我出的。不是你，是我。这不是派对游戏。这是严肃的工作，我宁愿咀嚼雷管，也不愿再听你的任何建议了。”片刻沉默后他说：“用雷管那段也许行得通。让我考虑一下再回复你。”
My performing career effectively ended the day my drug dealer moved to Florida to enter a treatment center. "How can you do this to me?" I asked her. "I have a piece to finish, damn it. I'm an artist, and I need to know where my drugs are coming from." I cashed in a savings bond left to me by my grandmother and used the money to buy what I hoped would be enough speed to last me through the month. It was gone in 10 days, and with it went my ability to do anything but roll on the floor and cry.
我的表演生涯在我毒贩搬到佛罗里达进入康复中心的那天彻底结束了。“你怎么能这样对我？”我问她，“该死，我还有件作品要完成。我是艺术家，我需要知道我的毒品是从哪里来的。”我兑现了祖母留给我的储蓄债券，用这笔钱买了我希望足够坚持一个月的冰毒。10天就没了，随之而去的是我除了在地板上打滚哭泣外做任何事的能力。
Speed's breathtaking high is followed by a crushing, suicidal low. Thinking I surely must've dropped a grain or two, I vacuumed the entire apartment with a straw up my nose, sucking up dead skin cells, Comet residue, and pulverized cat litter. Anything that traveled on the bottom of a shoe went up my nose.
冰毒令人惊叹的快感之后是令人绝望的低谷。以为肯定掉了一两粒，我用吸管吸着真空吸尘器清理了整个公寓，吸入了死皮细胞、清洁剂残留物和粉碎的猫砂。任何走在鞋底的东西都进了我的鼻子。
After a week, I left my bed to perform at the college, deciding at the last minute to skip both the Twister game and the march of the chocolate bunnies. I just heated up a skillet of plastic soldiers, poured a milkshake over my head, and called it a night. Thank you.
一周后，我离开床去学院表演，最后一刻决定跳过“扭扭乐”游戏和巧克力兔子的游行。我只是加热了一平底锅塑料士兵，往自己头上倒了一杯奶昔，就草草结束了那个晚上。谢谢。
David Sedaris recorded in Seattle. He's the author of many books, including most recently, Dress Your Family in Corduroy and Denim.
大卫·塞达里斯在西雅图录制。他是许多书的作者，包括最近出版的《穿灯芯绒和牛仔布的家人》。
[MUSIC - "THE COLLECTOR (AND THE ART MOB)" BY TERRY ALLEN]
[音乐 - 《收藏家（和艺术暴民）》，泰瑞·艾伦]
Coming up, views of artists in the art world that I swear are not quite so bleak. Also, what to think about the odd music Dad used to play and more. That's in a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，关于艺术界艺术家的观点，我发誓并没有那么暗淡。此外，关于我父亲过去播放的奇怪音乐的想法等等。一分钟后，来自国际公共广播电台的节目继续播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers and reporters and performers to tackle that theme. Today's program, Blame It on Art, stories about the difficulties and pettiness in artists' lives. We have arrived at Act Three of our program, Reverb.
这是《这就是美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，我们节目的每周都会选择一个主题，邀请各种作家、记者和表演者来探讨这个主题。今天的节目是“怪罪艺术”，讲述艺术生活中那些困难和琐碎的故事。我们已经进入了节目的第三幕，“回响”。
Ellery Eskelin never met his father, never even talked to him, but he always heard that he was a genius all during his childhood, and especially after he started playing sax when he was 10 years old, he heard stories about his dad. He said he heard that his dad could play any instrument he picked up, that he wrote music fast, like it was nothing, that he could never understand why other musicians got frustrated when he handed out brand-new arrangements right before a gig. He could always play it right off the page. Why couldn't they? Finally Ellery got to hear his father's music for the first time. What's happened since is a story about what it means to be a nobody artist and what it means to be called a genius. This American Life producer Nancy Updike tells the story.
埃勒里·埃斯克林从未见过他的父亲，甚至从没跟他交谈过，但他童年时期一直听说他是个天才，特别是10岁开始学萨克斯后，他听到了很多关于他父亲的故事。他说他听说他父亲拿起任何乐器都能演奏，写音乐快得惊人，就像轻而易举一样；他无法理解为什么其他音乐家在演出前拿到全新编曲时会感到沮丧，他总是一看谱就能演奏，为什么他们不能？终于，埃勒里第一次听到了他父亲的音乐。之后发生的故事是关于作为一个“无名小卒”艺术家意味着什么，以及被称作天才又意味着什么。本节目制作人南希·厄普代克讲述了这个故事。
When Ellery first heard his father's music, it was 1976, two years after his dad was killed. His father, Rodd Keith, fell, or jumped, from an overpass onto a California highway at 5:00 in the morning. Ellery was 17 when he first heard the tape, a talented and earnest jazz saxophone player living with his mother, who was also a musician.
埃勒里第一次听到父亲的音乐是在1976年，也就是他父亲去世两年后。他的父亲罗德·基思在凌晨5点从高架桥上摔下或跳下，跌落到加州的公路上。埃勒里第一次听到那盘磁带时17岁，是一个住在母亲家（她也是一名音乐家）的充满抱负的爵士乐萨克斯手。
I think we were just sitting in the living room of my mother's house in Baltimore. And, you know, we pop this cassette in.
我想我们当时只是坐在我母亲在巴尔的摩房子的客厅里。你知道，我们放进了这盘磁带。
Now, perhaps not surprisingly, when Ellery first heard this recording, he was really disappointed. He hadn't known what to expect when his grandparents sent the tape. But after all the buildup, he just couldn't believe that this was going to be it from his father, the genius, one crappy tape he couldn't stand listening to. And that was the last of his father's music he heard for the next 15 years.
现在，也许不足为奇的是，当埃勒里第一次听到这段录音时，他真的非常失望。祖父母寄来磁带时，他不知道该期待什么，但在经过所有铺垫后，他无法相信这就是父亲——那位天才的全部，一盘他听不下去的烂磁带。那是他之后15年里听到的最后一次父亲的音乐。
Let's play-- I'll just play this, and we'll talk about it. This is called "Hippy Happy Land."
我们来播放……我直接播放这个，我们讨论一下。这首歌叫《嬉皮快乐地》。
[MUSIC - "HIPPY HAPPY LAND" BY RODD KEITH]
[音乐 - 《嬉皮快乐地》，罗德·基思]
Is this your dad singing?
这是你爸爸在唱歌吗？
Yeah.
是的。
This is a song poem. Song poems are songs built around lyrics that people send in to companies that advertise in the back of some magazines. You're supposed to send in your lyrics, and then they'll write a song for you, record it, and send it out to record companies so you can break into the biz. Needles to say, the song poem industry is about half a promise short of a swindle and not a form that has launched any musicians you or I could name, except, interestingly enough, Hootie of Hootie & the Blowfish. Just kidding.
这是一首“歌曲诗”。歌曲诗是围绕着人们寄给某些杂志封底广告公司的歌词创作的歌曲。你寄去歌词，他们就为你写歌、录制，然后发给唱片公司，这样你就能闯入商业圈。不用说，歌曲诗行业离骗局只差一个承诺，而且它从未推出过你或我能叫出名字的音乐家，除了有趣的是，《胡蒂与河豚鱼》中的胡蒂。开玩笑的。
So it's 15 years since Ellery's first heard that tape of his dad, and he's thumbing through this music catalog. And he sees a CD compilation of song poems, including ones by Rodd Keith, his father. He was stunned. He immediately got the CD and started finding out everything he could about other song poems his dad wrote. It turns out he wrote hundreds and hundreds of them. Now Ellery has a whole shelf of 45s with song poems by his dad.
所以从埃勒里第一次听到那盘磁带已经过去15年了，他正在翻看一本音乐目录。他看到了一张歌曲诗的CD合集，包括了他父亲罗德·基思的作品。他震惊了。他立即买下CD，开始寻找关于他父亲所写其他歌曲诗的一切。原来他写了成百上千首。现在埃勒里的架子上摆满了父亲写的歌曲诗45转唱片。
This music has everything in the world going against it. It's completely artificial. It's a scam. I could probably list 15 different reasons why it shouldn't work. But for some reason, something comes through all this stuff. And I think that's part of the charm and attractiveness that it has.
这种音乐有一切不利因素。它完全是人工的，是个骗局。我可能能列举出15种为什么它不该成功的理由。但出于某种原因，某种东西穿透了这些堆积物。我认为这正是它所具有的魅力和吸引力的一部分。
The combination of the sentiment of the lyrics and the tune being so absurd, coupled with Rodd's delivery, which is actually like he's going for it. I mean, it's like a fine line between the fact that he knows that this is kind of a joke, but he's really trying to put something in it. And a lot of this stuff is right on that line. And I think that's almost an uncomfortable place to be, but it's really fascinating and attractive. It's like you want to cringe, but you're laughing, but you're really attracted to it all at the same time.
歌词的情感与旋律的荒谬结合，再加上罗德的演绎，他确实是在倾尽全力。我的意思是，这就像是一个微妙的界限，他知道这有点像是个笑话，但他真的试图在其中投入感情。很多作品都在这条界线上。我认为这几乎是一个令人不舒服的地方，但它确实非常迷人且具有吸引力。就像你想畏缩，但又在笑，但同时又深深地被它吸引。
Ellery loves that rawness and confusion of song poems and not in a theoretical, oh, isn't that kitschy way. He likes listening to them. He says he'll put on a song poem CD just to listen to around the apartment, the same as any other CD, which may sound unimaginable and breathtaking. But here's the thing, when you listen to one song poem after another, you realize song poems are like a blind date you start out thinking you're going to hate. And then by the end of dinner and a movie, you've found several things you really dig about this person. And even if you're not going to marry them, they're definitely not like anyone you've ever dated before.
埃勒里热爱歌曲诗的那种原始和混乱，不是理论上那种“噢，这不是很庸俗吗”的方式。他喜欢听它们。他说他会放歌曲诗CD，就像放任何其他CD一样在公寓里随便听听，这听起来可能难以想象且令人窒息。但重点是，当你一首接一首地听歌曲诗时，你会意识到歌曲诗就像一场一开始你以为会讨厌的相亲。然后在晚餐和电影结束时，你发现你对这个人有几个很欣赏的地方。即使你不会嫁给他们，他们也绝对不像你以前约会过的任何人。
[MUSIC - "THE FLITTING FIREFLY" BY RODD KEITH]
[音乐 - 《飞舞的萤火虫》，罗德·基思]
And so it is with fleeting loves, they sparkle for a while. But all too soon, they leave you on your senses to beguile. As we listened, it occurred to me that I had never heard a firefly used as a metaphor for love before.
这就是转瞬即逝的爱，它们闪耀了一阵子，但很快就会离你而去。当我们听的时候，我突然想到我以前从未听过用萤火虫作爱的比喻。
That's the great thing about the song poem. Every metaphor, every mixed metaphor that you could imagine is in there. And the topics are great. There's politics, love songs, hippies, dance crazes. Do the pig. Do the turkey. Space travel.
这正是歌曲诗的伟大之处。你能想象到的每一个隐喻、每一个混搭的隐喻都在那里。主题很棒。有政治、情歌、嬉皮士、舞蹈风潮。跳猪猪舞。跳火鸡舞。太空旅行。
The pig is not a dance that really made it big.
“跳猪猪舞”并不是真正风靡的舞蹈。
It should have, though. I mean, check it out. It would have if this had gotten an air play.
不过它本该风靡的。我的意思是，你听听看。如果这首歌能在广播里播放的话，它一定会火。
[MUSIC - "DO THE PIG" BY RODD KEITH]
[音乐 - 《跳猪猪舞》，罗德·基思]
The stylistic range of the songs Ellery's father wrote is dizzying. It's 10 years of work from someone who was very, very productive. Of course, he wasn't always working because sometimes he was busy doing things like taking LSD and going out on Sunset Boulevard wearing only a rain coat, and then accidentally catching the rain coat on fire when he tried to light a cigarette, and then taking the raincoat off and being arrested for public nudity. But when he was working, he would record, say, 30 songs a day, one right after another, no rehearsals, no second takes. So Rodd would record maybe some James Bond theme sounding song. Then a dance song. Then some psychedelic number. And then something that sounds like the early Beatles or Ray Davies.
埃勒里的父亲所写歌曲的风格范围令人眼花缭乱。这是一个非常、非常多产的人10年的工作成果。当然，他并不总是在工作，因为有时他忙于像服用LSD，仅穿着雨衣在日落大道上闲逛，然后试图点烟时不小心烧着了雨衣，脱下雨衣因当众裸露被捕。但当他工作时，他一天可以录制比如30首歌，一首接一首，没有排练，没有重录。所以罗德可能录制一首听起来像詹姆斯·邦德主题曲的歌，然后是舞蹈歌曲，然后是迷幻曲子，然后是听起来像早期的披头士或雷·戴维斯的曲子。
At first, when I was first listening to these records, I would hear things and not be sure it was him, even if it had his name on the label. It took me a while. Now I can tell it's him, no matter what he's doing. I can tell whatever that grain of-- whatever that is in his voice that makes it him, I can tell.
起初，当我第一次听这些唱片时，即使标签上有他的名字，我也会听到一些不确定是不是他的东西。花了我一段时间。现在不管他在做什么，我都能认出是他。我能听出不管那是什么——他声音里那种让他成为他自己的纹理，我都能辨认出来。
What an amazing way to know your father, that you have this sort of musical intimacy with him, that-- I mean, you never saw him face to face.
了解父亲的方式真棒，你和他有这种音乐上的亲密关系，虽然你从未面对面见过他。
Yeah, that's true. I can almost tell the songs that he wrote too, just by the devices that he used and the chord changes. Small, little things.
是的，没错。我几乎能辨认出他写的歌，仅仅通过他使用的手法和和弦变化，一些微小的东西。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
That's Ellery on the sax. It's from his first album, which is a collection of jazz standards. With his father on the other side of the country, that's the music Ellery grew up listening to and liking.
那是埃勒里的萨克斯演奏。出自他的第一张专辑，这是一张爵士标准曲合集。父亲在国家的另一边，这就是埃勒里从小听到大并且喜欢的音乐。
I used to be not a snob about it, because I've always had very broad tastes in music, but I definitely was brought up feeling that there was good music and that there was bad music. I mean, I grew up not liking rock and roll, which was really strange for somebody my age. Every kid in the first grade was talking about the Beatles and trying to get their hair to grow long. And I'm thinking about Stan Getz or John Coltrane or something like that.
我以前对这并不持势利态度，因为我的音乐品味一直很广，但我绝对是伴随着“有好的音乐，也有坏的音乐”这种观念长大的。我的意思是，我长大后不喜欢摇滚乐，这对我这个年纪的人来说真的很奇怪。一年级的每个孩子都在谈论披头士，都在尝试留长头发。而我在想斯坦·盖茨或约翰·柯川之类的。
By the time Ellery heard his father's music the second time, when he was in his early thirties, his musical taste had already changed and broadened. But the song poems were just a different world altogether. They were so unfettered by any pretensions of the art world or the world of serious music. It was inspiring. Ellery says in the last few years since finding his father's music and discovering song poems, he's been having a ball buying music he never liked or never heard as a kid and discovering he loves it. Iggy Pop, Yoko Ono, The White Album . And Ellery's own music is changing. Frankly, it's getting weirder, much less like jazz standards and much more like song poems. They have this experimental, "hey, let's see how this sounds" feel. It's making him a jazz outcast these days, which is fine with him. When a reviewer sniffed that a section of one of his albums sounded like, quote, "the buzzing of a thousand demented insects," his reaction was, "Yeah. And?"
当埃勒里第二次听到父亲的音乐时，他已经是三十出头，他的音乐品味早已改变和拓宽。但歌曲诗完全是另一个世界。它们不受艺术界或严肃音乐界任何虚荣心的束缚。这很鼓舞人心。埃勒里说，在找到父亲的音乐并发现歌曲诗的这几年里，他一直都在买他小时候不喜欢或没听过的音乐，并发现自己爱上了它们。伊基·波普、小野洋子、《白色专辑》。而埃勒里自己的音乐也在改变。坦率地说，它变得更古怪了，不像爵士标准曲，更像歌曲诗。它们有一种实验性的、“嘿，看看这听起来怎么样”的感觉。这让他最近成了爵士乐圈的异类，但他不在乎。当一位评论家冷嘲热讽说他一张专辑的一部分听起来像“一千只疯狂昆虫的嗡嗡声”时，他的反应是：“是啊，那又怎样？”
Was it a disappointment, something that you had to sort of go through and get over to think, OK, my father isn't the Mozart of jazz. Damn it, I'm not related to a Coltrane. I'm related to--
这是一种失望吗？你是否必须经历并克服这种想法，即“好吧，我父亲不是爵士乐的莫扎特。该死，我和柯川没有任何血缘关系。我与……”
But I think I am related to one. I mean, the music didn't change that.
但我认为我和一位天才有血缘关系。我的意思是，音乐并没有改变这一点。
Really?
真的吗？
No, people have told me. I mean, they use exactly those words. It's like, he was like a Mozart. He could write this. He could do that. All the cliches. But when people tell them, I can tell that they're really heartfelt. So my estimation of my father has never wavered, and I've never been disappointed in him. I've only been disappointed in the fact that I've never been able to find more of what he was able to do. Not that I'm dissatisfied with song poem music at all. I'm thrilled to have it. It's just that I know that there was more to his personality, and there was more to his life. And the fact that I never met him, I'm hungry for anything I can get.
不，人们告诉过我。我的意思是，他们正好用了那些词。就像，他就像个莫扎特。他能写这个，能做那个。所有的陈词滥调。但当人们告诉他们时，我能听出他们是发自内心的。所以我对父亲的评价从未动摇，我也从没对他感到失望。我只是对没能找到他更多作品感到失望。并不是说我对歌曲诗音乐不满意，我很高兴拥有它。只是我知道他的个性还有更多面，他的生活还有更多面。关于我从未见过他这件事，我渴望得到我能得到的一切。
I started out with almost nothing to go on except for that one cassette and two pictures. That was all.
我最初几乎一无所有，只有那盘磁带和两张照片。仅此而已。
If you could have a conversation with him now, what would you say?
如果你现在能和他对话，你会说什么？
Wow. Obviously, there are a million things I'd want to know. I just think it would be being with him that would be the whole thing. Not unlike these dreams in which, OK, he's here. We are together. And we're doing normal kind of stuff, like we're going to go out and hang out. W'ere going to do this. We're going to do that. And we're not going to call a huge amount of attention to the fact that there's this profound, enormous thing going on. We're not really going to address that so much as we're just going to live. We're just going to-- do you know what I mean?
哇。显然，有无数事情我想知道。我只是觉得能和他在一起就是全部了。就像那些梦里一样，好吧，他在那儿。我们在一起。我们做着正常的事，比如我们要出去玩。我们要这样做，要那样做。我们不会大肆宣扬这里正在发生某种深刻、巨大的事情。我们不会谈论太多，我们只是去生活。我们只是……你明白我的意思吗？
Would you want to play music with him?
你想和他一起演奏音乐吗？
Sure.
当然。
This is the one time in the interview you've cried. Why?
这是采访中你唯一一次哭泣。为什么？
Because I guess up to now, we've just sort of talked in terms of secondhand stories and things that I've thought a lot of that I'm able to recite, that I've said many times before, that I've thought about a lot, that I'm familiar with. I've been able to regulate my degree of emotion to that. But when you ask me to indulge in a fantasy or something like that, that's very direct.
因为我想直到现在，我们只是以二手故事和我想了很多、能背诵、说过多次、很熟悉的事情来谈论。我能够调节我对那些事情的情感程度。但当你让我沉溺于某种幻想之类的东西时，那是非常直接的。
He never met his father. It's not just that he died. Ellery never met him. Ellery says losing his father has only gotten harder as he's gotten older. When we talked, he'd just passed the age his father was when he died, 37. Ellery's father appears on Ellery's new album, Green Bermudas. About half the songs sample song poems written by his father and some other song poems too.
他从未见过他的父亲。不仅仅是因为他去世了，埃勒里从没见过他。埃勒里说，随着年龄增长，失去父亲变得越来越艰难。我们交谈时，他刚好过了他父亲去世时的年龄——37岁。埃勒里的父亲出现在埃勒里的新专辑《绿色百慕大》中。大约一半的歌曲采样了父亲写的歌曲诗，也包括其他一些歌曲诗。
[MUSIC - "GREEN BERMUDAS"BY ELLERY ESKELIN WITH ANDREA PARKINS]
[音乐 - 《绿色百慕大》，埃勒里·埃斯克林与安德里亚·帕金斯]
Ellery's father reminded me of this writer Philip K. Dick, who spent his life doing this intricate science fiction writing, all the while dreaming of writing something entirely different, something that would be considered great literature, huge and influential, a classic, not just a cult sci-fi hit. He died young and obscure. But now, 25 years after his death, you've probably seen some of his work without even realizing it. His sci-fi stories and novels have spawned or influenced an astonishing number of films, Blade Runner, Total Recall , The Matrix , Minority Report , The Truman Show , A Scanner Darkly. A collection of his writing is now in the Library of America in the company of Twain, Whitman, Roth.
埃勒里的父亲让我想起了作家菲利普·K·迪克，他一生都在创作精巧的科幻小说，同时梦想着创作完全不同的作品——一些会被视为伟大文学、巨大且具影响力、成为经典的作品，不仅仅是邪典科幻畅销书。他在年轻时默默无闻地去世了。但现在，在他去世25年后，你可能已经看过他的一些作品却没意识到。他的科幻故事和小说催生或影响了惊人数量的电影：《银翼杀手》、《全面回忆》、《黑客帝国》、《少数派报告》、《楚门的世界》、《盲视》。他的文集现在进入了美国图书馆，与马克·吐温、惠特曼、罗斯并列。
I think most of us are like that, like Philip Dick or Ellery's father. Most of us are toiling away at daily work that doesn't seem as important to us as the ambitious dreams we have for ourselves. We're convinced that we're not living up to our potential, that there's a better part of ourselves that just hasn't expressed itself yet. Until the day our lives are over and what's left is that daily work, whatever it is, whatever we gave it.
我认为我们大多数人都是这样，像菲利普·迪克或埃勒里的父亲。我们大多数人都在劳作着日常工作，在我们看来，这远不如我们对自己怀有的雄心勃勃的梦想重要。我们确信自己没有发挥出潜力，还有一个更好的自己还没有展现出来。直到生命结束的那天，剩下的只是那些日常工作，无论那是什么，无论我们付出了什么。
Act Four, Grace Note.
第四幕，装饰音。
To end our program on a more hopeful note, we have this story from Joel Kostman. It details some of the bitterness that we've heard from others so far this hour about the life of artists, plus something else we haven't. Joel Kostman is a locksmith in New York city. This is from a book of stories he's written about his experiences on the job.
为了以更有希望的方式结束我们的节目，我们有这个来自乔尔·科斯特曼的故事。它详细描述了我们在本小时内从其他人那里听到的关于艺术家生活的一些苦涩，以及我们没听说过的东西。乔尔·科斯特曼是纽约市的一名锁匠。这摘自他撰写的关于工作经历的故事集。
"A musician is a peanut," he says. The musician sits on a chair and talks to me while I work. He's wearing a nicely ironed white, short-sleeve shirt and a pair of green chinos. His hair is black, flecked with gray. It's short and neatly combed. "Yeah," he says. "Nothing but a damn peanut."
“音乐家就是个花生，”他说。音乐家坐在椅子上，在我工作时跟我聊天。他穿着一件熨烫平整的白色短袖衬衫和一条绿色卡其裤。头发是黑色的，夹杂着灰白。短而整齐。 “是啊，”他说，“除了该死花生之外什么也不是。”
He lives in a tiny, one-room apartment underneath the Manhattan Bridge. Trains roar by overhead. Sometimes the noise is so loud, it is difficult to hear what he is saying. "I never should have gone to Juilliard," he says. "It really messed up my perspective."
他住在大曼哈顿桥下一间极小的单间公寓里。火车在上方隆隆驶过。有时噪音太大，很难听清他在说什么。“我不该去茱莉亚学院的，”他说，“它真的搞乱了我的视角。”
He stands and walks over to the kitchen, which is a sink and a half refrigerator. There is a hot plate sitting on the counter beneath a homemade shelf on which some cups are stacked next to a few plates. Two sauce pans hang from hooks from the shelf. "You're in your own special little classical world there. It's not the real world. Musicians don't rate in the real world. Took me years to get that straight." He opens the refrigerator and removes a pitcher. "You want some iced tea?" "No, thanks," I say. He pours a glass for himself.
他站起来走进厨房，那里只有一个水槽和一个半大冰箱。台面上有一个电热盘，下面是一个自制架子，架子上堆着一些杯子，旁边放着几盘子。两个平底锅从架子上的钩子上垂下来。“你当时处在你那个特殊的古典世界里。那不是真实世界。音乐家在真实世界里排不上号。我花了几年时间才搞清楚这点。”他打开冰箱拿出一个水罐。“要喝冰茶吗？”“不用了，谢谢，”我说。他给自己倒了一杯。
"All I ever really wanted to do was play popular music," he says. "But I was just a kid. What did I know? Juilliard was my parents' idea. I came all the way from Hawaii. Luckily, I was smart enough to drop out." "What instrument do you play?" I asked. "Guitar. You know what really bugs me?" "What?" "Americans can't play Hawaiian guitar. They only copy."
“我真正想做的只是演奏流行音乐，”他说，“但我那时只是个孩子。我知道什么？茱莉亚学院是我父母的主意。我大老远从夏威夷过来。幸运的是，我有足够聪明选择退学。”“你演奏什么乐器？”我问。“吉他。你知道什么让我特别烦吗？”“什么？”“美国人不会弹夏威夷吉他。他们只会模仿。”
I have already figured out what's wrong with his lock. It'll be an easy repair, so I allow myself the opportunity to continue the conversation. "You know, there was a hit song when I was a kid," I say, "came out in the '50s. It was called 'Hawaiian Love Song' or something like that. It was an instrumental with the Hawaiian guitar." I sing a little of what I think was the melody. "Right," the musician says. "Americans. That was typical. The big hit Hawaiian guitar song was done by Americans. Junk."
我已经弄清楚了他的锁有什么问题。修理起来很容易，所以我让自己有机会继续谈话。“你知道，我小时候有一首热门歌曲，”我说，“是50年代出来的。叫《夏威夷情歌》之类的。那是一首用夏威夷吉他演奏的器乐曲。”我哼了一点我认为是旋律的部分。“没错，”音乐家说，“美国人。那很典型。那首最热门的夏威夷吉他曲是美国人做的。垃圾。”
"When that song came out, though, there was a lot of work for us. I spent years on the road playing Hawaiian music. Spent some great days in Kansas City. Ever been there?" "No," I say. "Great town. I played with some fine musicians. First-class gig all the way. Didn't last long, though. Harder times after that."
“不过那首歌出来时，我们有很多工作。我在路上演奏夏威夷音乐好几年。在堪萨斯城度过了一些伟大的日子。去过那里吗？”“没有，”我说。“伟大的城市。我和一些优秀的音乐家一起演奏。全是顶级演出。不过没持续多久。那之后日子更难过了。”
We hear the sound of an instrument coming from outside. The musician frowns and walks to the window. He's stirring the sugar around in his glass. I look too. There's a guy leaning up against a car playing a saxophone. "He thinks he can play," he says. "You know him?" The musician sips his tea. "Unfortunately," he says. "He wouldn't know good music if he tripped over it."
我们听到外面传来乐器的声音。音乐家皱着眉头走到窗边。他在搅拌杯子里的糖。我也看了看。有个家伙靠在车上在吹萨克斯。“他以为他会吹，”他说，“你认识他？”音乐家喝了一口茶。“不幸的是，”他说，“如果好音乐绊倒他，他都认不出来。”
The sax player looks up and waves. "You almost ready?" he calls. The musician yells, "B flat." Then he steps back into the room, and he says, "What an idiot. He makes the same mistake every time."
萨克斯手抬起头挥了挥手。“差不多准备好了吗？”他叫道。音乐家大喊：“降B调。”然后他走回房间说：“真是个白痴。他每次都犯同样的错误。”
"I'm almost finished here," I say. "Take your time," he says. "We're only going to Staten Island. The wedding's not till 3:00. He's not paying me enough to get there early."
“我这儿快修好了，”我说。“慢慢来，”他说，“我们只是要去斯塔滕岛。婚礼要到3点才开始。他付我的钱不足以让我早到那儿。”
I am engaged to be married in two months. My fiancee, Rebecca, and I have hired a classical trio to play at our wedding. "So are you in a band? I ask. The musician laughs to himself. "Not a chance. His guitar player's sick. Every time his guitar player gets sick, he calls me to bail him out." A train rattles by. The cups and plates shake. "I'm a bartender," I think he says.
我还有两个月就要结婚了。我的未婚妻丽贝卡和我雇了一个古典三重奏在婚礼上演奏。“所以你在乐队里吗？”我问。音乐家自己笑了。“没门。他的吉他手病了。每次他的吉他手生病，他就会叫我去救场。”一辆火车咔哒咔哒开过。杯子和盘子晃动起来。“我是个调酒师，”我听他这么说。
"So are you finally ready?" the sax player asks. He's sitting on the hood of the car, holding his instrument between his legs. "No," the musician growls. "I just came down with my guitars to tell you I'm going to be another 20 minutes."
“所以你终于准备好了吗？”萨克斯手问。他坐在车盖上，把乐器夹在两腿之间。“没有，”音乐家咕哝道。“我带着吉他下来只是为了告诉你我还要再过20分钟。”
A group of six kids is standing a few feet away, watching. Two Chinese girls, three early adolescent black boys, and a little white boy who couldn't be more than five with a marine-type brush cut. They look like they are posing for a family portrait, tallest in the rear, the little one in the middle, everyone waiting to say, "Cheese." "Friendly guy, huh?" the sax player says to me. "That's the only reason I give him a chance to go on these gigs, because he's such a nice guy. He can't play a lick." "Right," the musician says.
一群六个孩子站在几英尺外看着。两个中国女孩，三个青春期早期的黑人男孩，还有一个看起来不超过五岁、留着海军式平头的小白人男孩。他们看起来像是在拍家庭合影，最高的在后面，小的在中间，每个人都在等着说“茄子”。“友好的家伙，哈？”萨克斯手对我说。“这就是我给他机会参加这些演出的唯一原因，因为他是个好人。他连一点技术都没有。”“没错，”音乐家说。
The sax player is middle-aged with a salt-and-pepper goatee. He's wearing a small black cap, the kind Pete Seeger wears, with a snap in the front over the brim. "Get the lock fixed?" he asks. "Yes," I say. He lifts the horn to his lips and begins to play. I recognize the melody. "Going to the Chapel and We're Going to Get Married." I wonder if we can get the classical trio to work up this tune.
萨克斯手是中年人，留着灰白的山羊胡子。他戴着一顶黑色小帽子，皮特·西格戴的那种，帽檐前有个按扣。“锁修好了吗？”他问。“好了，”我说。他把号角举到嘴边开始演奏。我认出了旋律。“我们要去教堂结婚了。”我想知道我们能不能让古典三重奏也练练这首曲子。
[MUSIC - "GOING TO THE CHAPEL" BY BARRY WINOGRAD AND JOHN SIEGLE]
[音乐 - 《我们要去教堂》，巴里·威诺格拉德与约翰·西格尔]
One of the Chinese girls, who's about 9 or 10, starts clapping. She holds the palms of her hands straight up like cymbals and alternately brings one down onto the other. The rest of the group joins in. Each one moves differently, one swaying, one lifting and dropping his shoulders to the beat. The sax player slides off the car and holds the instrument out toward them while he plays. They start to dance around him. He hops up onto the sidewalk, and the kids follow. He circles the car with the kids in tow. "Gee, I really love you, and we're going to get ma-a-arried." A young black woman appears out of nowhere and is standing next to the car singing. She has what sounds to me like a professional voice. The musician nods and smiles at her. "Going to the chapel of love," she croons.
其中一个大约九十岁的中国女孩开始鼓掌。她把手掌垂直向上举起，像铙钹一样交替拍打在一起。团队其余的人也加入了。每个人动作不同，一个在摇摆，一个随着节拍上下耸动肩膀。萨克斯手从车上滑下来，边吹边把乐器伸向他们。他们开始绕着他跳舞。他跳上人行道，孩子们紧随其后。他带着孩子们绕着车转圈。“天哪，我真的爱你，我们要结婚了。”一个年轻的黑人女性从某个地方出现，站在车旁唱歌。她有着听起来像专业的声音。音乐家向她点头微笑。“去爱的教堂，”她哼唱着。
People on the sidewalk across the street stop and begin clapping too. A train goes by on the Manhattan Bridge directly above us. The kids are still dancing. The people are clapping. And the sax man is playing. But all I can hear is the train. After about 15 seconds, the noise subsides, and I hear the sound of a guitar.
街对面人行道上的人停下脚步，也开始鼓掌。一列火车在我们正上方的曼哈顿大桥上开过。孩子们还在跳舞。人们在鼓掌。萨克斯手在演奏。但我只能听到火车的声音。大约15秒后，噪音减弱了，我听到了吉他的声音。
The musician, with one foot up on the fender of the car, is playing a rhythmic accompaniment. He smiles at me. The sax player comes up and stands next to him. They pick up the pace, and the people clap faster and faster. Finally, while the sax man is playing a string of cascading notes, the musician, strumming furiously, lifts his guitar handle into the air and brings it down with a chop. They end at precisely the same moment. We all applaud enthusiastically. "OK, let's go to a wedding," the musician says.
音乐家一只脚踩在车翼子板上，弹奏着有节奏的伴奏。他冲我微笑。萨克斯手走过来站在他身边。他们加快了速度，人们的掌声也越来越快。最后，当萨克斯手吹出一串瀑布般的音符时，音乐家疯狂地扫弦，把吉他琴头举向空中，然后狠狠地砍了下来。他们精确地在同一时刻结束。我们所有人都热烈鼓掌。“好吧，去参加婚礼吧，”音乐家说。
Joel Kostman's book is Keys to the City: True Tales of a New York City Locksmith.
乔尔·科斯特曼的书是《城市之钥：纽约市锁匠的真实故事》。
Our program was produced today by Julie Snyder and myself with Alix Spiegel and Nancy Updike. Contributing editors Sarah Vowell, Jack Hitt, and Margy Rochlin. Our senior editor for this show was Paul Tough. Production help from Alex Blumberg, Laura Doggett, Emi Takahara, [? Sahini ?] [? Davenport ?], and [? Vija ?] [? Navarro ?]. [? Shojow ?] [? Young ?] runs our website. Barry Winograd played sax, and John Siegle played guitar in our rendition of "Going to the Chapel."
我们今天的节目由朱莉·斯奈德和我本人制作，艾莉克斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普代克参与。特约编辑萨拉·沃威尔、杰克·希特和玛吉·罗克林。本节目的高级编辑是保罗·塔夫。制作协助来自艾历克斯·布隆伯格、劳拉·多格特、艾米·高原、萨希尼·达文波特和维加·纳瓦罗。肖乔·扬管理我们的网站。巴里·威诺格拉德演奏萨克斯，约翰·西格尔在我们的《我们要去教堂》翻唱版中演奏吉他。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can get our free weekly podcast or listen to old shows online.
《这就是美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。我们的网站www.thisamericanlife.org，你可以在那里获取我们的免费每周播客或在线收听旧节目。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who meets with his music staff every single week, looks at their playlists, and declares--
WBEZ管理监督托雷·马拉蒂亚，他每周都会与音乐人员开会，查看他们的播放列表，并宣布——
This music has everything in the world going against it. It's completely artificial. It's a scam.
这种音乐有一切不利因素。它完全是人工的，是个骗局。
And we started today's program with Leonardo da Vinci. Let's end with Leonardo as well. This is a quote from one of his notebooks. "To the ambitious, for whom neither the bounty of life nor the beauty of the world suffice to content, it comes as penance that life for them is squandered and that they possess neither the benefits nor the beauty of the world. And if they are unable to perceive what is divine in nature, which is all around them, how will they be able to see their own divinity, which is sometimes hidden?" I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我们以列奥纳多·达·芬奇开始了今天的节目。让我们也以列奥纳多作为结束。这是他笔记本中的一句话：“对于那些雄心勃勃的人来说，世间的富足和世界的美丽都无法使之满足，对他们来说，这是一种惩罚，因为他们虚度了生命，既没有享受到世间的利益，也没有感受到世界的美丽。如果他们无法感知周围神圣的大自然，他们又怎能看到自己内心有时隐藏的神性呢？”我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带回更多《这就是美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。